[Music]
[Applause]
the party carried on late into the night
scotland fans out in voice in london
after their team kept their dreams of
progressing into the next round of the
euros alliance
[Applause]
it came after the oldest fixture in
international football was played out as
a goalless draw at wembley
john stone saw his header come back off
the woodwork while che
adams went close for scotland england
dominated first half possession
but attended scoreless scotland's first
chance for the second half fell to
lyndon dykes
who saw his shot cleared by rhys james
england brought on jack grealish to try
and unlock the scottish defense
and swapped harry kane for marcus
rashford to no avail
the best effort of the second half came
scotland's way
adams again going close for england
much to reflect on after a rather
lethargic 90 minutes
but scotland would view this as a heroic
point gained
brilliant fantastic master class
absolute masters class for steve clark
yeah
we've got a point it rolls on to to
tuesday night and then
first time in the lifetime we're going
to qualify for a major championship we
were about a team and deserve to win but
it was a good point though it's a good
point to point give us a chance to get
through winning
tuesday we will go through england now
have to beat czech republic on tuesday
to win the group
scotland lower win against croatia could
be enough to see them into the last 16.
ticketless fans were warned not to
travel to london
and the metropolitan police say they
made a total of 30 arrests for a range
of offenses throughout the day
fans were eventually cleared from
leicester square in the early hours of
the morning
and as the scots head home they'll be
hoping for even more celebrations to
come
shingi marurike sky news